the great wonder of the elder scrolls
online is that it's fantastical sights
and sounds can inspire great
anticipation such vast landscapes must
Harbor grand adventures to go on and
epic tales to hear unfortunately it too
often turns out that these are simply
illusions of grandeur and not the real
deal it's single player fantasy
experience does not provide the emergent
adventuring for which the Elder Scrolls
series is known and it's massively
multiplayer side is diminished by the
game's tendency to punish you for
playing with others the Elder Scrolls
online more or less captures the fantasy
vibe you'd want from an Elder Scrolls
game at least the character creation
offers plenty of customization options
including four classes and a number of
familiar Elder Scrolls races and once
you leave the introductory dungeon the
possibilities are exciting the game's
sparse heads-up display and fully voiced
conversations pull you into the world
and the quests wisely avoid the kill 20
goblin cliches that plagued the genre
unfortunately in leaving behind the
usual MMOG questing cliches and focusing
on lengthy conversations with NPCs the
Elder Scrolls online creates different
kinds of problems as you move from one
place to the next you hear the same few
actors over and over again that may not
have been such a sin if their voices
weren't so distinct and recognizable and
if the game's writing focused on
developing characters rather than
pouring lore into your head you could
levy the same criticism against previous
Elder Scrolls games but where the single
player games focused on letting you
craft your own story this one doesn't
offer the same kind of freedoms and so
you move through Tamriel in the
prescribed direction trudging through
one long-winded tale after another
instead of conjuring one to call your
own luckily many of these tales are
intriguing ones during my travels I
stumbled upon a village with a terrible
secret and had to decide whether to free
its residents from their curse or leave
them haunted by the truth my favorite
moments for those in which I saw a story
come to life rather than
having it read to me from a script sadly
grouping with others hurts the games
attempts to immerse you when it's
stories you frequently make choices that
are then reflected in the world around
you thanks to the game's phasing
technology this is a neat touch until
you join other players you and a buddy
might enter a region only to have your
teammate turn invisible because he has
made a different choice and thus has
entered another instance in these ways
the game actively discourages you from
grouping with others this isn't to say
that the game doesn't provide some
opportunities for players to come
together with 4 player dungeons leading
the way it's easy to find a group and
get into a dungeon once you've reached
the appropriate level the action is fine
but it never crackles in part due to the
lifeless animations Elder Scrolls combat
has always been somewhat messy but it's
real-time nature usually communicates a
sense of played against flesh the Elder
Scrolls online combines old-fashioned
hotkey combat with the action-oriented
swordplay too mixed results you target
using an on-screen reticle and combat
timing is confined mainly by your mana
and stamina bars not by skill cooldowns
you can also block attacks and tumble
but this is not true action combat you
aren't limited to any given type of
weapon or armor however no matter which
class you choose and weapon types have
various skills associated with them
there's a good deal of freedom in how
you spend skill points which you spend
not just in combat skills but in
crafting skills as well the Elder
Scrolls online is at its best in its
player vs. player campaign here the
game's three factions fight for control
of Cyrodiil when the action heats up
battles are a lot of fun whether you and
your comrades are setting up a line of
defensive ballistas at the top of it
keeps walls or going for broke and
charging a nearby farm protected by NPCs
getting to a battle like this requires a
bit of patience however due to Serie
Dill's vast expanses and quick travel
limitations the Elder Scrolls Online's
technical troubles such as its array of
broken quests can be patched it's less
certain however that the single-player
and multiplayer sides of this
fantastical coin will ever complement
each other
that's too bad because when the stars
aligned the game seems poised for
greatness
hopefully the Elder Scrolls online will
one day get out of its own way souls of
the hard weapons